hi it's matthew martin from details it
earlier today at the Calvin Klein show
we saw a wonderful presentation of
utilitarian minimal simplicity there was
a uniformity to all the look to the
super rugged and masculine even though
the pieces themselves are really
specific and very tailored i love that
it was all about a monochromatic you
know berry Calvin it was like a top and
a pan and a shoe and that's it and there
was also some layering that for him i
thought was new and interesting there's
a lot of deaths in the collection a lot
of them had these great patch pockets
another good use of layering was that I
love that there was a lot of coats over
codes there would be like a top coat
over you know a more structured almost
keycode ish type of blazer Calvin is
really known for that sort of simplistic
layering and I thought here was really
great throughout the show there were
these wonderful slim cargo pants and I
love that he showed them with both
dressy and you know more casual sporty
pieces the cargo pants been around
forever people making a swim forever but
by far this is the slimmest sleekest
chicest cargo pant I've ever seen in my
life the one piece of the show that I
think you should definitely invest in is
those really great tunic tops that we're
like puffer top you know there's
something that you can wear on their own
with the pair of jeans and it's going to
be a really new way to modernize an
update your wardrobe for more videos
from Milan please go to details calm and
be sure to follow me on instagram and
twitter at details matt
you